the couple leaving right now is Simone
and Sasha I want to start off on the
perfect night
you got like perfect scores both dances
and I obviously know things took a shift
after that but I mean coming off that
high I mean that was a massive
accomplishment did you feel that shift
that change I did and I feel like for me
that's a win in itself whether America
votes for it or not it's it for me it's
like it's time I feel like I've been out
of high so much the experience is
wonderful I feel like I found out a lot
about myself not just a gymnastics
moment but like normal sweat really do
seem peppy and happy and you got a big
smile I mean like for you the essence
that I get is that it's about doing the
best that you can do and sometimes
that's the bronze yes and this isn't my
element if you were gymnastics I've like
you know what Simone you better get back
in the gym but I don't know how to dance
in heels this was like something I was
still tripping yesterday literally has
been a dream come true to work with and
she's grown so much as a person and I
wish it was in that final I wish she won
this whole competition and I wish the
best for I'm gonna be there cheering her
on at the next Olympics huge sign saying
go Simone does in building giggles who's
gonna win in my every shot
[Music]